[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission à ne pas
manquer si vous êtes un passionné de
sport local c'est parti pour le sommaire
de ce magazine tumbling nous aurons avec
nous dans cette émission axel duriez de
sportifs licenciés aux clayes-sous-bois
est devenu vice champion d'europe dans
cette discipline rattacher la fédération
française de gymnastique son coach rené
et baby sera également avec nos
interviews à suivre golf links et
européennes s'est déroulé pendant trois
jours au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines au rang des
voix regrouper des amateurs et des
professionnels dont le numéro deux
français antoine ros leur reportage dans
quelques instants
volley-ball conflans andrésy jouy
termine sur le podium du championnat
élite
contrat rempli pour cette équipe qui
avait de grandes ambitions en début de
saison nous aurons avec nous le
président du club
l'actualité sportive c'est maintenant
sur tb 78
[Musique]
je vous disais dans les titres en
tumbling discipline de gymnastique
acrobatique axel duriez des
clayes-sous-bois rebriller le double
champion du monde chez les 13-14 ans a
réussi à se hisser jusqu'en finale des
as championnat d'europe à sotchi en
russie début mai mais les blinois de 16
ans a finalement perdu en finale de
l'épreuve le français s'est incliné
contre le russe dimitry à chatalov l'un
des favoris de ce rendez vous pour nous
parler de cette performance nous avons
avec nous via écran interposé axel
duriez et son coach rené et ben ami
bonsoir on voit alors comment vous
sentez vous vous êtes de retour ici à en
france aux clayes-sous-bois comment vous
sentez vous êtes vous avez pu
redescendre un petit peu de votre petit
nuage axel baila mois depuis repris ma
vie normale sur ton et unifiée et je
vous promets que pas et tout ça niko moi
j'ai étudié vous défendiez même si c'est
toujours une fierté pour moi même ont
ils pu suivre défendu entre élèves et la
vie normale reprend et vous de votre
côté rené mais je suis dans l'art
gothique je suis redescendu de résine de
ses émotions genre la semaine de repos
parce que c'est une semaine fatigante à
une semaine des passeports comme ça les
compétitions c'est ça n'est rien mais
c'est fatigant psychologiquement parce
que voilà il ya des pressions il ya des
choses qui font qu'on rentre on est un
peu au bout du rouleau
mais voilà j'ai tout appareil vous
normal on prend les entraînements
à partie de la semaine prochaine donc
voilà est ce que vous avez pu bien fêter
cette médaille au sein du club également
des clayes-sous-bois c'est compliqué
parce que je pense que vous êtes au
courant qu'il ya des restrictions
sanitaires et de regroupement donc on
aimerait bien affecté mon voile a fêté
en attendant bientôt du passé
à partir du 9 mai ça s'appelle possible
donc on compte bien le faire et pour la
france ne pas le faire parce que nous
n'allons pas l'autorisation de pouvoir
se réunir
voilà donc rien fait alors c'est votre
première médaille européenne pour votre
première participation en finale
est ce que c'est une surprise axel bah
moi au début je partais dans l'optique
plus de voir pour me qualifier en finale
appel si j'étais en finale voire pour
faire une médaille comme tout temps
quand je pars en font paître tout en
forme qu'il est là il ya une pression
particulière sur ce rendez vous j'ai pas
vu il n'y avait pas de pression
particulière sur ce rendez-vous à la
pression j'en ai souvent l'argument
c'est à dire que en compet
internationale
finalement j'ai pas de pression je ne
stresse pas particulièrement et c'est
peut-être ça qui fait que ça
impressionne les autres se disent bon
coaching à et que je sais je fais appel
je connais mon connais mal servi et je
prenais de télé faire alors vous
finissez donc deuxièmes de ce rendez
vous est ce que c'est quand même une
déception
axel bah oui comme je pense tous
sportifs qui arrivent en complète
internationale le but est d'être le
meilleur
là j'ai fais pas tu déçu puisque valve a
fini 2e mais en vrai dans l'intérieur de
moi je suis content parce que j'ai fait
mais servi j'ai fait de mon mieux et
j'avais fumé série g fit le plus que je
pouvais après voilà il a gagné ma part
le bandit la prochaine pas on verra qui
gagnera
rené pamiers est ce que vous êtes un
petit peu déçu pour axel qui n'est pas
a réussi à décrocher cette offre cette
médaille d'or non pas du tout c'est vrai
que je m'accorde bien ces petites de
questions et je savais en fait que on
aime demandé je suis pas déçu moi je
remets les 10 dans je vous mets du
faisan la hâte dans l'or c'est que six
médailles internationales 6 médailles
européennes
donc moi médaille de bronze et d'argent
médaille d'or évidemment lorsque pour
mieux parce que bien quoi d'être
reconnaissants pour mieux que d'être des
deuxièmes mais de repartir avec une
médaille je pense qu'il ya plein de comm
ses concurrents peuvent avoir cette
médaille là qu'ils n'ont pas eue
donc j'ai pas déçu et et encore ils
n'auraient raté ça ces séries non mais
alors on aura un représentant à dommages
n'a pas performé aussi bien que plus le
faire mais là il était vraiment au
maximum et ce qu'il devrait faire
vraiment s'il était il a été
impressionnant il ya meilleur que lui ce
jour là voilà on accepte la dent
l'acceptent la supériorité de
l'adversaire russes qui étaient là et je
suis un petit regret mais je n'ai pas
façon son placement c'est juste je pense
que le jugement est un peu dur avec lui
sur une tête de série je sais pas si je
voudrais envoyer les séries et la
première est une série qui les lie les
stadiers aucun pas de réception et
mérite d'être noté plus plus que ce
qu'elle a été notée mélange je ne suis
pas juge international c'est ma vision
des extérieurs et de voilà matches à
l'extérieur
je pense qu'il a été par l'internaute à
sa juste valeur bon après maintenant ce
qui fait qu'à d'autres que j'ai pas vu
et que les juges ont estimé que ça
méritait cela je n'irai pas contre les
juges mais c'est vrai que tout était
sévère par rapport à ce que moi je n'y a
plus de voir par rapport à ce qu'il a
réalisé comme série je trouve que
c'était un peu durement noté mais
maintenant et j'ai pas trop changé dans
la nuque à ce moment donc voilà
justement ma petite déception c'est seul
que j'ai mais lui alors sa performance
son compteur suis très fier parce qu'il
l'a marqué des points il a montré qu'il
faudra compter sur lui dans les années à
venir quand il sera en seniors axel j'ai
cru comprendre vous n'étiez pas à 100%
physiquement oui c'est vrai c'est que je
me suis blessé trois semaines avant je
me suis fait une subluxation à l'épaule
gauche
du coup je ne pouvais pas être en forme
voilà prend des entraînements c'était
compliqué puisque j'avais mal et on va
éviter de forcer dessus parce que
maintenant ça risque de s'aggraver et du
coup bah c'est vrai que j'étais pas à
100% mais j'ai fait un bal a les
meilleures séries je sache faire encore
du coup je n'étais pas en forme c'est
vrai mais j'ai fait quand même de mon
mieux et j'ai fait le meilleur que je
pouvais faire de la veille d'une épaule
en état est ce que vous confirmez
dimitri chatalov qui vous a battu vous
battra pas deux fois axel non je veux
pas avoir j'espère pas en tout cas pour
moi et une mon but c'est qu'ils ne
remettent pas justement mon but est de
continuer à gagner donc je pourrais
gagner et après 6 me baba ça va faire
que me donnait plus la rage pour la
prochaine fois de revenir et de me dire
ma nuit s'est dit qu'il faut que je
batte cette fois et voilà alors je le
rappelle un cette discipline n'est pas
inscrite au programme des jeux
olympiques elle était seulement inscrits
au programme des jeux olympiques en 1932
à los angeles
est ce que rené est ce que c'est un peu
dommage pour un pont axel de ne pas
pouvoir briller sur la scène
internationale au niveau des jeux
olympiques
ôté mon combat depuis des années parce
que je suis persuadé c'est pas parce que
je suis un passionné mais je pense que
c'est nous qui méritent d'être vues qui
ya travaillé derrière qui est énorme qui
est énorme et je pense que si jamais
l'été aux jo je pense que franchement il
y aurait déjà des téléspectateurs parce
que voilà c'est un sport très
spectaculaire
donc j'espère est élevé abstrait ou
souffraient justement qu'ils soient à
paris de 1024 belle une belle image du
web français qui performe aussi bien que
ça être aux jeux olympiques de 2024 est
comme en rêvent mais bon je ne suis pas
décideur à ce niveau là dernière
question axel quel est votre programme
pour pour les prochains mois alors les
programmes l'importance d'établir mon
épaule elle prendre soin de mon corps
faire plus attention à tout ce qui est
la ferme encore avec nous ça va devenir
un vrai sportif de haut niveau ce qui
est bon enfant c'est pas que je suis en
forme bien au contraire
c'est maintenant fait que j'écoute passé
mon corps malheureusement du coup c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut que j'apprenne
à faire et qu'on me reproche ce
encore jeune en compet à l'inter depuis
s'écouter mon corps mais du coup c'est
un programme que j'ai fait faire pour
apprendre et ensuite reprendre les
entraînements dès que possible
et voilà merci à tous les deux d'être
intervenu sur cette émission vous
souhaite de remporter encore plus de
médailles dans les prochaines années et
on continuera évidemment à vous suivre
axel merci beaucoup
bonne soirée alors on va maintenant
prendre la direction du golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines pendant trois
jours 120 joueurs et joueuses
professionnelles ou amateurs étaient
présents sur le site évinois pour
participer au linxea open le rendez-vous
a notamment tiré des têtes d'affiché
dont antoine rosner des images de justin
brasier un montage de rémi lefebvre le
linxea open a débuté ce jeudi 6 mai sous
la pluie au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
le rendez vous organisé par la
fédération française de golf rojo près
de 120 sportifs sur trois jours de
compétition le tournoi est mixte et il a
pour objectif de mêlée à la fois les
amateurs et les professionnels français
il ya deux amateurs pas partir moi je
joue avec deux amateurs de jeunes eux ça
leur permet de jouer avec des
professionnels ça leur permet de jouer
sur un parcours de compétition
avec ba comme prévu un temps assez
compliqué
ces amateurs ont également eu le
privilège de jouer avec antoine or other
le pensionnaire du golf de la boulie à
versailles le numéro deux français est
venu se préparer avant de s'envoler pour
des tournois aux états unis très content
c'est un peu dommage avec la météo
voilà c'est comme ça je suis très
content c'est un très bon entraînement
pour moi le parcours est superbe donc
non très content de pouvoir faire de
3,18 euros ici au golf national
l'autre star de ce rendez vous est
également le parcours les jours se sont
testés sur ce 18 trous qui a accueilli
les meilleurs joueurs du monde pendant
la ryder cup 2018 et la magie opère
toujours bien avec les valeureux c'est
un des parcours le futur du de france un
petit peu après je pense qu'il ya
plusieurs mais surtout avec les
conditions de paris c'est un golf
historique
ça c'est un plaisir de venir jouer dans
le golfe depuis la ryder cup est encore
meilleur qu'avant
donc oui forcément forcément c'est
vraiment des moments privilégiés le
tournoi league c'est européenne s'est
terminée ce samedi 8 mai sur les greens
de l'albatros chez les dames inès archet
remporté la compétition chez les hommes
antoine ros nord s'est imposé avec un
score final de 5 coups en dessous du par
seul hic c'est à open était aussi
l'occasion pour le golf national de
renouer avec la compétition de haut
niveau pendant cette crise sanitaire
nous avons pu rencontrer le directeur du
golf national philippe pilato le premier
jour de l'épreuve
nous sommes au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines à mes côtés à
philippe pilato le directeur du golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
alors philippe qu'est ce que ça
représente le linxea ffgolf pour le golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
mais pour nous c'est une belle
opportunité et c'est vrai que de
recevoir recevoir ce tournoi sur cette
semaine semaine qui était et est dédié à
l'open de france c'était c'est une
excellente nouvelle pour pour pour
l'ensemble des équipes parce qu'en fait
le site a été conçu pour pouvoir
recevoir des compétitions de haut niveau
des compétitions professionnelles
compétitions amateurs de haut niveau et
retrouver un petit peu l'élite l'élite
française sur le site du golf national
c'est une main j'ai quelque chose
d'extraordinaire ça s'est fait un petit
peu à la dernière minute ça s'est passé
comment ben en fait ça s'est passé que l
open de france l'open de france est
reportée dans le calendrier
et donc mais on avait cette semaine
l'actualité un jeu presque de la crise
sanitaire et donc voilà donc on avait
une semaine vacante des équipes
mobilisées sur l'événement et un
parcours qui avait été commencé à
préparer on avait on avait préparé le
parcours de façon à ce qu'ils soient
opérationnels pour l'open de france est
donc en fait ce qui s'est passé c'est
que la fédération a trouvé à trouver un
sponsor sponsors qui s'est positionné de
façon à pouvoir accueillir cet événement
cela permet au golf national de
continuer un petit peu sa vie d'avant si
je peux dire d'avoir des compétitions de
haut niveau
bah oui oui c'est exactement ça c'est
vrai que l'ensemble des collaborateurs
sur le terrain c'est vrai que ça donne
ça donne sommes dans nos objectifs
dans l'année ça permet de mobiliser les
équipes ça permet
de sortir un petit peu de la zone de
confort et de proposer de proposer
quelque chose enfin un produit qui est
en tout cas un parcours qui est qui fin
prêt pour accueillir ce tournoi oui vous
le disiez les jardiniers tous ceux qui
s'attachent à rendre ce golf national si
beau voulait absolument des compétitions
aussi c'est important pour les employés
du golf national
bah oui c'est important parce qu'en fait
on est on a été éduquée et dopé aux
compétitions de haut niveau c'est vrai
qu'on a eu la chance d'accueillir
beaucoup de potes de france d'accueillir
les championnats de france des jeunes
des championnats d'europe
les championnats du monde la ryder cup
en 2018 hélas d'accueillir des
événements tels que linxea pour nous c
est ça permet vraiment de redonner un
objectif et un coup de boost aux équipes
oui il n'y a pas de public ici est ce
que c'est un regret ouais c'est toujours
un regret c'est vrai que deux voilà
lorsqu'on lorsqu'on met beaucoup
d'énergie à préparer des événements
lorsqu'on met beaucoup d'énergie à
préparer des terrains on mais on a envie
de partager c'est vrai que là on partage
pas m'aimer mais il n'empêche que il
n'empêche que le principal c'est de
pouvoir donner la possibilité à des
joueurs professionnels et de joueurs
amateurs de pouvoir jouer c'est la
priorité
mais j'aime beaucoup aussi un des
animaux de golf juste avant le linxea
open au golf national le numéro deux
français antoine ros nord a reçu une
invitation de la part des organisateurs
de deux tournois du pga tour le circuit
américain dont il n'est pas encore
membre
kevin mois 70e mondiale jouera dès cette
semaine le byron nelson que le mémorial
début juin de bonnes nouvelles qui
récompense ses prestations de ca
derniers mois en football et plus
précisément en ligue des champions
laventure des parisiens s'arrête au
stade des demi finales de la compétition
les joueurs qui s'entraînent au camp des
loges à saint germain en laye ont perdu
au match aller au match retour face au
joueur de manchester city
les citizen les ont battus 2 1 à l'aller
2-0 au retour les coéquipiers de neymar
ne remporteront donc pas la ligue des
champions tant espérée depuis l'arrivée
des katas des qatari dans la capitale
française en championnat le psg continue
à viser le titre mais les franciliens
ont fait match nul contre rennes et ont
désormais trois points de retard sur
lille à deux journées de la fin du
championnat
toujours en football ou à liddes et
mesloub l'ancien footballeur de lorient
et lens a été mise en examen pour recel
de blanchiment de drogue
le joueur aurait
une aire de trappes pour aujourd'hui âgé
de 35 ans est soupçonné d'avoir des
liens avec l'homme présenté comme la
tête du réseau surnommé le chinois cet
homme aurait notamment utilisé des
voitures immatriculées au nom du
footballeur ainsi que l'un de ses
comptes bancaires à son insu son avocat
affirme que walid mesloub ignorait tout
des activités du trafiquant a présumé en
volleyball le club du nord du
département conflans andrésy jouy est
assuré de terminer sur le podium en fin
de saison du championnat élite c'est les
hymnes au sont pour l'instant 3e donc à
un match de la fin du championnat
derrière avignon et harnes et ils
attendent le résultat de leur match
contre lyon mais le club ne montera pas
cette saison le club pourrait plutôt
tenter l'aventuré la saison prochaine
pour nous parler de cette actualité nous
avons avec nous via écran interposé le
président du club philippe mon tournoi
bonsoir bonsoir alors est ce que vous
êtes satisfait de cette troisième place
qui n'est pas officielle mais qui
devrait l'être dans les prochains jours
alors en fait elle est acquise puisque
cet après midi j'ai reçu un avis de
notification de la fédération qui me
kiki qui arrête le championnat il
restait un match à faire contre lyon et
comme il n'y a pas de danger ni pour la
montée ni pour les descentes et que
toute façon lyon n'aurait pas pu non
attrapé donc le championnat s'est arrêté
aujourd'hui cet après midi on restera
troisième derrière avignon et harnes
mais devant deux des grosses villes
comme marseille grenoble lyon mais c'est
vraiment une belle satisfaction
est ce que vous êtes satisfait du coût
de cette troisième place à ce qu'elle
était espéré en début de saison c'était
un petit peu un objectif quand même il
faut l'avouer en début de saison on
avait
par une belle équipe on a des bons
recrutements on a des bases solides avec
des joueurs qui sont fidèles au club
depuis un moment ça tournait bien donc
on s'était donné comme objectif d'être
dans le haut du tableau et on est à
l'arrivée malgré savez tous tout le
contexte de cette saison a été gâchée
par les reports quelques blessures qui
sont arrivées un peu plus que les années
passées en france on regarde ce qui
s'est passé nous parfois ce sont des
accidents et donc ouais saison difficile
pas de public
si pour nous aider parce que notre
gymnase est bien rempli et puis le
septième homme vous êtes bien souvent
donc non c'est une belle satisfaction
vvb saison l'année un peu différente des
autres
alors vous étiez plutôt en milieu de
classement pour une partie de la saison
puis vous être remonter petit à petit il
remonta dahan comme on dit dans le
milieu en sait bien ça ouais on a volé
le début de saison est un peu chaud on
est obligé de serrer un peu les listes
de temps en temps c'est pas toujours le
sport c'est à toujours que de l'amitié
puis parfois c'est une idée des
réprimandes et se remettent un peu
appliqué les consignes bossé dur en
musculation à respecter toutes les
consignes tactiques parce que je peux
vous dire que tous les matches ont
préparé par le staff de manière
irréprochable on a toutes les vidéos
sait exactement comment je vous les
autres comment les genres pourra tout ça
donc bon voilà quelques blessures et
puis j'ai pu s est tourné un petit peu
difficilement mais bon après on a remis
les pendules à l'heure les joueurs sont
super à mystic hui résultats sont par
ailleurs avec notamment une très belle
victoire armes qui est premier de la
poule il ya quinze jours
qui aurait cru que on allait pouvoir
battre une équipe qui est qui n'a que
deux défaites dans sa saison à quel
moment l'équipe a trouvé son rythme
est ce qu'il ya eu un moment précis dans
la saison en fait juste après le
juste après les vacances de décembre ont
travaillé très fort au niveau reprises
je pense aussi que bon il faut le dire
quand vous avez un nouveau passeur qui
le place de quelqu'un qui arrive depuis
qu'ils étaient là depuis six sept ans où
l'équipe se jouait un petit peu
facilement parce que connaissance et
puis habitude mais il fallait trouver un
peu le rodage
bien qu'il soit de 10 les très bons vins
ce n'est pas de soucis débat ça passe a
reculé de pro b qui jouait un peu plus
vite qui voit là avec des habitudes un
peu différentes et donc va le temps que
cet amalgame se fasse avec quelques
petites blessures
là notre capitaine qui a faim de jouer
sur trois postes différents pendant
pendant les trois premiers mois donc il
a joué le réceptionneur attaquant mais
il a joué aussi
elle aa pointe comme on dit pointue et
puis centrale face et qu'on était
vraiment dans une situation un peu
difficile lié aux blessures à partir de
janvier
si bien bien remis le groupe été
performant tout ce qu'on allait créer
puis préparer portes situées surtout
comme vous avez quelques histoires qui
avaient visionné près les autres c'est
dans l'enchaînement de la dynamique et
puis ça fonctionne bien
alors vous avez parlé du commis de 19 et
du rythme un petit peu étrange qu'il a
mis en place cette saison
est-ce qu'il fallait être fort
mentalement pour réussir une performance
comme celle que conflent a réalisé cette
saison
obligatoirement c'est pas une saison
comme un autre pour un joueur parce que
quand vous êtes mobilisés vous avez
travaillé toute la semaine qu'au dernier
moment vous dis bah y'a des claques au
vide dans l'équipe
chikhi de vialer le joueur s'était
préparé bon c'est finalement le la
tension retombe
et puis fort on va leur préparer annoncé
qu'on leur jouera avec décalage
donc on n'a pas pu tellement faire de
prévisions c'est un petit peu au jour le
jour les équipes vont les accueillir
alors où ils pouvaient
le rap est d'être à converser vient chez
nous est plus beaux timbres que si vous
voulez jouer à 15h et je vois 15 heures
donc tout ça ça a été voilà un peu
perturbant et donc ma le mérite en
revient à nos joueurs qui sont bien
adaptés à à ce calendrier un petit peu
tronqué où il fallait s'adapter
chaque semaine dallas question quels
seront les objectifs pour la saison
prochaine rapidement écoutez on vous
réfère aux aussi bien et puis et puis on
va naître une marche supplémentaire on
devrait amener l'équipe éventuellement
pour pouvoir postuler un jour à jouer en
pro b ces terres qu'on l'a à court terme
pendant dix ans il sera trop vieux mais
voudrait c'est mettre une marche pour
commencer à préparer l'équipe pour
pourquoi pas jours-ci tutoyait ce niveau
qu'on n'a jamais pu atteindre le
le problème principal c'est d'avoir des
joueurs encore plus investit donc on
augmente les entraînements l'année
prochaine vont en faire un
supplémentaire de 2 je suis là
supplémentaires et puis on a beau
recrutement donc une première marche
voilà peut-être pour un jour et si
possible à court terme montrent et
pourquoi pas en pro b
merci à vous philippe mon tournoi on
continuera évidemment à vous suivre dans
les prochaines années on espère voir le
club le plus haut possible au classement
et dans les divisions
merci beaucoup philippon trop noirci
plaisir en basket le jeune victor webb
anyama n'en finit plus de surprendre le
joueur de 17 ans passé par le chesnay
versailles était de nouveau titulaire
dans le cinq de nanterre contre le
portel le prodige évinois de deux mètres
19 a passé trente et une minutes sur le
parquet de ce match première division de
nouveau installé au poste de pivot le
basketteur a marqué 7 points délivré 4
passes et pris 9 rebonds
il a permis à son équipe de gagner d'un
point 76 à 75 prochain match pour victor
webb anyama ce mercredi sur le terrain
de chalon sur saône à
jouars-pontchartrain habitants décidé de
se lancer un défi faire le tour de la
corse à bord d'un vélo électrique un
projet pensé depuis plusieurs mois qui
mêle sport écologie et solidarité
mathieu récolte des fonds
pour lou une petite fille à deux savent
ils attendent une maladie entraînant un
fort handicap physique et mental en
portage de bixente mes rayons
santisteban un moteur des rétroviseurs
un toit en panneaux solaires
mathieu chanfreau assemblée un vélo pas
comme les autres c'est un vélo à trois
roues que j'ai acheté d'occasion
également que j'ai électrifié avec une
entreprise qui dans le sud de la france
qui s'appelle déclic échos qui m'a bien
bien aidés qui m'a aidé aussi pour le
tout la partie support des panneaux et
puis le test je les fais ya deux jours
seulement donc juste deux semaines avant
de partir en corse un bolide qui servira
à faire le tour de la corse dès le 13
mai prochain
700 kilomètres en une semaine pour un
dénivelé global de 10000 m en attendant
son départ mathieu s'exerce à la
maîtrise de son nouveau vélo vélo
électrique m'a redonné goût au vélo m'a
remis en forme aujourd'hui je fais des
distance de 80 km en vtt que je faisais
pas avant donc ça marche dans les deux
sens en fait on peut passer du vélo
électrique au vélo bio et du vélo bio à
l'électrique
une expédition pensait en novembre
dernier avec un ami dans laquelle il
manquait quelque chose
moi il me manquait une dimension un peu
humaine
dimensions utile à ce projet là et donc
j'ai parlé à nico que j'avais vraiment
envie d'essayer de trouver quelqu'un
pour ont pu quand tu suis aidé en fait
pas forcément une grosse association un
peu impersonnel mais quelqu'un dans
notre entourage notre village et c'est
un peu le hasard ou je ne sais pas ça
s'est passé un peu naturellement deux
jours après je tombais sur un poste de
sur facebook 2ème ligne mais qui est la
maman d'une petite fille polyhandicapée
d'un joueur pontchartrain dans un mot
qui est juste à côté
et donc j'ai pris contact tout de suite
et on s'est vu le lendemain et basse a
accroché mathieu a décidé d'utiliser son
projet pour médiatiser la maladie de lou
6 ans atteinte du syndrome de rett
c'est la maladie qui touche le plus de
petites filles en france le côté sportif
nous a tout de suite plu parce que nous
on est on est une famille de sportifs
on a été un petit peu bloquée par le
handicap de loups pour pouvoir faire
plein de choses et malgré son handicap
c'est vrai qu'on fait encore beaucoup de
sorties vélo donc en fait on accroche sa
poussette au vélo de ludovic la plupart
du temps une cagnotte participative a
été mise en place pour soutenir les
traitements rares et coûteux de loups le
premier palier à 2000 euros pour un
fauteuil permettant un loup une assise
confortable a été atteint maintenant la
cagnotte participative aide au
financement de l'école équithérapie un
ensemble de soins physiques et mentaux
par les chevaux encore un mot de
cyclisme la ville de mantes la jolie a
reçu le nouveau label ville à vélo du
tour de france une distinction qui
récompense quatre ans à villes
françaises et européennes qui ont reçu
au moins une fois une étape du tour de
france depuis sa création en 1903
concrètement les communes vont avoir une
pancarte dans leurs ruches sur le modèle
des villes fleuries la ville de mantes
la jolie aura deux vélos sur quatre la
ville évinoise avait notamment accueilli
le tour de france en 2020
et on termine par un rendez-vous une
course connectés solidaire et est
organisée par la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux l'événement est
programmée de ce dimanche 23 mai au
dimanche 30 mai le concept vous pouvez
faire du sport seul ou à plusieurs quand
vous voulez pendant à cette période
l'objectif est de faire le plus de
kilomètres possible à pied ou à vélo
votre effort permettra de collecter des
dons profit de la boutique alimentaire à
bali ski de saint quentin en yvelines la
ville remet remettra un cadeau aux
participants plus d'informations sur le
site internet de la commune
c'est la fin de cette émission
merci d'avoir suivi à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]